bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors c'est un
nouvel exercice de communication ligne
directe un marathon annuel pour vladimir
poutine d'abord que dire sur le format
de cette émission
ce format montre évidemment que vladimir
poutine et les autorités russes plus
largement l'olm à venir à un canal de
communication avec la population alors
bien sûr si sans doute organisé
d'ailleurs ça n'explique très
certainement une organisation très
complexe sans savoir qui va parler qui
va pas parler vu le nombre de personnes
intéressées mais ça montre en tout cas
l'intérêt de développer des formes de
relations entre la population et les
autorités qui disent on est assez
original par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
connaître dans d'autres pays où ce qu'on
connaît dans d'autres pays et qui montre
que la russie à la recherche de méthodes
de communication entre la société entre
le bas de la société et ses élites
ce qui mériterait sans doute d'être
examinée par d'autres systèmes
politiques d'autres dirigeants
politiques dans le monde
jules et la crise de ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie occidentale aujourd'hui ça
peut être intéressant de regarder ce que
font d'autres sur le sujet et je pense
que ça a sur ce plan-là la méthode
inauguré par le président poutine mais
au moins intéressant alors c'est vrai
que c'est une émission qui intervient
une intervention en tout cas dans un
contexte particulier à bien après
justement son sommet avec son homologue
américain joe biden et puis dans un
contexte de recrudescence au sien de la
pandémie notamment à moscou avec le
variant indien donc ce n'est pas
forcément un exercice aisé pour le
président russe cette fois alors c'est
pas forcément un exercice aisé en même
temps bon c'est vrai que la rencontre de
genève a très certainement été un succès
pour vladimir poutine nous on n'a qu'à
regarder les médias du monde entier y
compris les médias occidentaux pour
constater sur une forme ou sous une
autre que poutine est rentré à moscou
sur la tête haute donc ça c'est
évidemment pour lui et pour ses
compatriotes
un succès incontestable maintenant la
question de la pandémie c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus complexe commencez la
russie a une politique à l'égard de la
pop up pandémie un peu différente de
celle des pays occidentaux
elle a très tôt développé son propre
vaccin
et bien sûr il ya toujours un certain
cas tony moore s'est pas vraiment
comment les choses vont se développer
mais on voit bien quand même que il ya
quelqu'un au poste de commandement à
moscou pour eux tranchez les éventuelles
divergences qui peuvent exister à
l'égard du vaccin comme dans toute
société
le confrontés à ce problème alors
justement vladimir poutine qui s'est
positionné un concernant le vaccin il a
déclaré être contre une vaccination
nationale obligatoire mais il a quand
même invité les rues à écouter les
experts et finalement à se faire
vacciner et vous l'avez bien des larmes
ici qu'à son propre vaccin spoutnik
mais quand même cette question est-ce
que c'est facile on en russie et
finalement de se faire vacciner manière
tout ouïe
disons qu'une chose c'est connu la
population russe n'avait pas l'air très
intéressés à se faire massivement
vacciner et puis on peut dire que les
russes ont montré que je parle de la
population une certaine négligence à
l'égard du de la pandémie
ce qui d'une certaine façon montre que
c'est une population assez confiante
puisque elle ne tombe pas dans cette
espèce de catastrophisme qu'on a connu
dans les pays occidentaux mais en même
temps peut-être qu'on peut considérer ça
comme une certaine insouciance et que
villa située vu l'évolution de la
situation et surtout l'émergence des
soupes des nouveaux variants le
gouvernement le pouvoir ici a voulu
réagir et donner un coup de
l'accélérateur se dire au processus de
vaccination parce que la situation elle
est quand même tendu ça concerne pas
seulement la russie en c'est le cas en
france était dans d'autres pays du monde
aussi avec ce variant delta le variant
indien concernant la stratégie plus
globale global de lutte contre la
pandémie
la stratégie russe qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire la stratégie russe d'abord une
stratégie qui vise évidemment à
contrôler les choses en russie et en
même temps à faire le maximum pour que
les pays étrangers
ce qu'on perd dans une vision dégager de
l'emprise des blocs et c'est là
évidemment ou ce qu'on peut regretter
c'est que depuis un an
même sur ce terrain on a eu une espèce
de guerre froide on voit bien la
difficulté que le vaccin russe comme
d'autres d'ailleurs
rencontre dans l'union européenne par
exemple ou dans d'autres pays
occidentaux montrent bien qu'il n'ya pas
une volonté de coopération pour des
intérêts sanitaire supérieur au dessus
de la conjoncture politique ou même
politicienne et ça c'est très
regrettable même si en plus évidemment
il faut être fou pour voir le côté
pécunier de la chose bien sûr que les
grandes entreprises pharmaceutiques
occidentales ont eu aussi intérêt à
verrouiller si je peux dire au moins le
maximum de marché dans les pays
occidentaux
donc là effectivement la politique russe
sur ce plan là est beaucoup plus ouvert
comme d'ailleurs celle d'autres pays
comme la chine au cuba et
on peut simplement regretter que le
climat de guerre froide ses joies aussi
élargi a jugé qu'ils auraient dû faire
l'unanimité
alors justement il ya des sujets aussi
qui ont été évoqués ça concerne
globalement l'intégrité territoriale de
la russie avec l'ukraine et la crimée
également sur ces dossiers là par
exemple sur l'ukraine le président russe
qui déclare ne pas être contre une
rencontre tout de même avec le président
ukrainien mais ils n'en voient pas
l'intérêt en raison je cite de d'un
contrôle de l'ukraine par l'extérieur
oui alors ça fait que sans doute un
petit et si je peux dire un petit coup
de patte de poutine à son homologue de
kiev qui qui est en quelque sorte poussé
à manifester une plus grande
indépendance ce qui peut être évidemment
intéressant puisque à la suite du sommet
de genève
on voit quand même que au moins une
partie de la d2 élites américaines sont
prêts à un certain nombre de concessions
un peu partout dans le monde à l'égard
de la russie et les probables évidemment
que la question de l'ukraine sera à un
des éléments ou la russie test racisme
dire la capacité de compromis des pays
occidentaux
d'une certaine façon ce que poutine dit
à hélène ski c'est prenez votre
indépendance et nous négocierons
directement pour le moment on se
rappelle quand même que celle qui a été
élue cotre pour rochelle quo
c'est-à-dire contre la politique d'
allégeance totale de l'ukraine envers
les pays occidentaux et que depuis qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir il n'a visiblement
pas pu ou voulu prendre les moyens de
cette de cette indépendance certaine
façon je pense que le président poutine
en s'adressant à zelensky sous cette
forme qui peut apparaître évidemment un
peu condescendante est aussi une façon
de lui dire mr redevient indépendant et
puis on pourra négocier directement mais
bon effectivement la question c'est
évidemment de savoir qui va décider et
qui décide à kiev entre les etats-unis
et les autres puissances occidentales et
les différentes forces locales dont j'ai
l'aide ce qui n'est qu'une qu'une
émanation parmi d'autres merci à vous
vélo brusque et historien spécialiste de
l'europe de l'est est maître de
conférences à l'inalco